نحن في المنزل الذي قام الجيش الاسرائيلي
بتفجيره من ضمن ثلاثه منازل تم تفجيرها
بشكل كامل وسبعه منازل بشكل جزئي الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بانه عثر على مخبر
للمتفجرات في احدى الشقق الشقق وكان وقام
بتفجيرها اكثر من 400 جندي وضابط اقتحموا
مخيم بلاطه وحاصروا هذا المنزل صاحبه
المنزل ام سامر تحدثت الى العربيه وقالت
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي حاصر المنزل وبدا
باطلاق النار ثم انسحب وبعد انسحابه
بحوالي عشر دقائق انفجر المنزل وكان وكانت
العائله موجوده في الطابق العلوي المنزل
شبه مدمر بالكامل وحضرونا
جميع الجهات المختصه من التواجد تحت سقف
الطابق السفلي خشيه من انهياره لان اعمده
المنزل منذ الصباح وهي
تتساقط منها قطاع هذا ما حدث العمليه
اسفرت عن مقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين واصابه
خمسه
بالرصاص الحي واكثر من 75
اخرين اصيبوا جراء استنشاقهم للغاز المسيل
للدموع قبل ان ينسحب الجيش الاسرائيلي
ويعتقل سبعه فلسطينيين من مخيم بلاط
الثلاثه الذين قتلوا خالد هل هم من قاطني
هذا المنزل والمستهدف بهذه العمليه ام
انهم ربما قتلوا بسبب المواجهات مع القوات
الاسرائيليه
لا لا هم لم يكونوا متواجدين في المنزل
كانوا متواجدين في منطقه اسمها حاره
الجماسين قتلوا خلال الاشتباكات
المسلحه شهود العيان لم ينفو ولم يؤكدوا
بانهم كانوا من ضمن المسلحين الذين اطلقوا
النار على الجيش الاسرائيلي ولكنهم اكدوا
بان الثلاثه لم يكونوا متواجدين في محيط
المنزل الذي تم تفجيره صباح هذا اليوم طيب
خالد ما الذي يفسر لجوء اسرائيلي لاستعانه
بهذا العدد الكبير من الجنود والضباط
تتحدث عن 400 جندي وضابط يعني هل يعد ذلك
طبيعيا اذا ما قرن
بالاعداد المشاركين في اقتحامات السابقه
لا يعني مثلا اخر اقتحام لمخيم جنين اكثر
من
وضابط شاركوا هذه المره الجيش الاسرائيلي
يتحدث عن 400 جندي وضابط ربما لحجم
المقاومه
يلقاها الجيش الاسرائيلي داخل مخيم بلاطه
لطبيعه العمليه التي
دخل الى المخيم بسببها الجيش الاسرائيلي
والمخابرات الاسرائيليه للبحث بحسب بيان
العسكري للجيش الاسرائيلي بانهم وجدوا
مخبرا لتصنيع المنافجرات قاموا بتفجيره ما
ادى الى تدمير ثلاثه منازل وتضرر سبعه
اخرى نعم لمتابعه المزيد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات